el número tiene muchas clases de
propiedades asombrosas solo como un
repaso al número en lo puedes ver como
el límite cuando entiende infinitud de 1
más 1 / n esto elevado a la n que por
cierto también lo podemos ver como el
límite cuanto n tiende a cero de uno más
n elevado a la 1 entre n pero en lo que
vamos a enfocar este vídeo es en una de
las propiedades más impresionantes de
una de las tantas propiedades asombrosas
pero creo que esta es la más relevante
en el cálculo y es la noción de que si
tomamos la derivada con respecto a x de
a a la x ok
aquí es donde va el redoble de tambor
esto debe de ser igual
a la x
al menos para mí esto me parece
maravilloso y es que déjame mostrarte
una gráfica para que apreciemos lo que
te digo esta es parte de la gráfica de
igual
a la equis y lo que dice aquí es que la
derivada con respecto a x de ea la x es
a la x es decir la pendiente de la recta
tangente en cualquier punto de esta
función es igual al valor que toma la
función en ese punto vamos a observarlo
si vemos aquí donde nuestra función toma
el valor de 1 la pendiente de la recta
tangente también toma el valor de 1 y
por ejemplo aquí el valor de la función
es 2 y la pendiente de la recta tangente
también toma el valor de 2 y aquí el
valor de la función es 4 y la pendiente
de la recta tangente también toma el
valor de 4 así que podrás seguir porque
esta es una de las cosas increíbles de
él pero ahora en lo que quiere enfocarme
es en demostrar esta derivada es decir
quiero que usemos nuestra definición de
derivada recuerda la derivada con
respecto a x en este caso de ea la e
es igual y pongamos al límite cuando
delta de x tiende a 0 de eb elevado a la
equis más delta de x menos a la equis
entre delta de x ok
dado esto hagamos un poco de
manipulación algebraica kim para ver si
podemos llegar a algo mejor y demostrar
esta derivada tengo que esto es igual al
bueno al límite cuando delta de x tiende
a cero y aquí solamente voy a usar las
propiedades de los exponentes y voy a
escribir esto como a la x x ala delta de
x observa solo estoy usando las
propiedades de los exponentes menos este
a la x entre delta de x pro claridad
observa que esto es lo mismo que esto
ahora puedo factorizar de aquí un x y de
hecho como x no se afecta cuando delta
de x tiende a cero entonces lo puedo
sacar del límite así que hagamos eso voy
a factorizar
a la x y lo voy a sacar del límite lo
vamos a sacar por completo porque no se
ve afectado por delta de x entonces esto
va a ser igual a elevado a la x por el
límite cuando delta de x tiende a cero y
que me queda bueno me queda el elevado a
la delta de x menos 1 entre delta de x
bien y ahora nos vamos a poner un poco
más elegantes con nuestros límites lo
que vamos a hacer es lo que se conoce
como un cambio de variable entonces lo
que voy a decir es bueno no sé cómo
encontrar directamente este límite pero
tal vez puedo simplificarlo y quién sabe
tal vez pueda encontrar algunas de las
formas descritas aquí arriba así que qué
pasa si hago aquí una sustitución voy a
decir que n sea igual a am elevado a la
delta de x menos 1 por lo tanto cuál es
el valor de delta de x en términos de n
veamos si sumamos uno de ambos lados me
queda que n
uno es igual ha elevado la delta de x y
xi ahora sacamos el logaritmo natural
logaritmo en base de ambos lados obtengo
que el logaritmo natural de n más uno es
igual a delta de x y ahora lo podemos
sustituir todo en este límite esto lo
podemos sustituir por esto y esto de
aquí arriba lo podemos sustituir por n
y qué le pasaría al límite bueno cuando
delta de x tiende a cero a que se
aproxima n ok veamos si delta de x
tiende a cero esto implica que entiende
bueno si delta de x tiende a cero aquí
arriba tendrían elevado la 0 es igual a
1 -1 lo cual es cero
entonces n tiende a cero inclusive
también lo puedes ver por acá abajo
observa el logaritmo natural de 0 más
uno es igual a logaritmo natural de 1
que es igual a 0
así que si delta de x tiende a cero esto
implica que n tiende a 0 ahora puedes
reemplazar este límite cuando delta de x
tiende a 0 y ahora decir que es el
límite cuando n tiende a 0 es más déjame
reescribir todo esto este es el paso más
elegante de toda la demostración me
queda
a la x que multiplica al límite cuando n
tiende a 0 y recuerda voy a poner cuando
n tiende a 0 porque como ya vimos si
delta de x tiende a cero esto implica
que en
tiende a cero y viceversa y en el
numerador me va a quedar simplemente n y
delta de x es simplemente el logaritmo
natural de n 1 perfecto ya tengo esta
expresión de aquí y ahora en que nos
beneficia bueno qué va a pasar si
dividimos el numerador y el denominador
por n entonces voy a multiplicar acá
abajo por 1 entre n y voy a hacer lo
mismo que arriba el numerador me queda
simplemente 1 y el denominador a que va
a ser igual bueno podemos usar ahora
nuestras propiedades de los logaritmos y
decir que esto va a ser igual a ea la x
que multiplica al límite cuando éste
tiende a 0 de 1
/ y ahora para escribir esta parte que
tengo aquí abajo voy a usar una de
nuestras propiedades de los logaritmos
más importantes recordemos si tenemos a
por el logaritmo natural debe bueno eso
es lo mismo que el logaritmo natural de
bem elevado a la aap esta es parte de
nuestras propiedades de los logaritmos y
porque nos va a servir bueno porque
entonces la parte de abajo nos va a
quedar como el logaritmo natural de n 1
es más para que te sea más claro déjeme
ponerlo como el logaritmo natural de uno
más en esto elevado a la 1 entre n el
lugar y tmo natural de todo esto y ahora
estoy seguro que eso te resulta bastante
familiar porque lo que acabamos de
construir se parece mucho a lo que
tenemos acá arriba mirá acá arriba
teníamos el límite cuando n tiende a
cero de uno más en el elevado a la 1
entre n y de hecho podemos usar nuestras
propiedades de los límites
porque este uno no es afectado por el
límite y entonces podemos decir que y
ahora si nos aproximamos en la recta
final tengo a la equis que multiplica a
uno
entre el logaritmo natural del límite
cuando n tiende a 0 déjame escribir lo
del límite cuando n tiende a 0 de ken de
uno más en el elevado a la 1 entre n y
ahora que es esto que tengo aquí adentro
del logaritmo natural es decir a que es
igual el límite cuando n tiende a cero
de uno más en elevado a la 1 entre n
bueno ya lo habíamos dicho acá arriba
esta es la definición de observa es lo
mismo que tenía que arriba esto es
simplemente y si ahora sustituyó a todo
esto por el que me va a quedar bueno me
va a quedar elevado a la x que
multiplica a 1 entre el logaritmo
natural de porque esto era él y ahora
cuánto vale el logaritmo natural de a
qué potencia tengo que elevará a él para
obtener
bueno eso es simplemente uno así que
esto nos queda como a la equis y hemos
acabado acabamos de demostrar que la
derivada con respecto a x de ea la x es
igual a e a la x y bueno a mí esto me
parece sorprendente esto nos muestra una
dimensión más de la belleza de este
número y espero que lo hayas disfrutado
y nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo